this video is brought to you by
curiosity stream and nebula
the earth's atmosphere is complicated
wind seems to blow in every direction
changing day by day and sometimes hour
by hour but there are regular repeated
winds for example the etecian wind blows
every summer in the aegean sea and the
mistral in southern france every winter
but the most regular fixed part of the
atmospheric circulation is the trade
winds a band of fast moving air moving
from east to west near the equator all
year long these winds have had a huge
influence on human history enabling
intercontinental travel for centuries
before aircraft but what causes them and
how do they form the first step in our
modern understanding of the trade winds
lies behind me at the royal society in
london within a very particular map but
before looking at that map i need to
introduce you to a very important person
not keith the head librarian at the
royal society though he is important too
but this guy this is one of my favorite
royal society scientists this is edmund
halley for most people halley is the
name they associate with the comet what
were the other sort of big contributions
to science that he made it's actually
quite difficult to to enumerate the war
because there were so many you can see
here his model of the interior of the
earth so he was a bit of an earth
scientist he was a sea captain uh he
produced a diving suit that he wore and
demonstrated he also predicts the
transit of venus and that's why people
like captain cook go off to to make
observations in cook's case in tahiti so
halle is a big figure
just a few accomplishments hallie has an
amazing place in the history of physics
he is responsible for the publication of
possibly the most significant scientific
work of all time newton's principia
paying for its publication after the
royal society spent all of its money on
an admittedly lovely volume on the
history of fish but hallie was not just
an enabler he did amazing science
himself in particular he was interested
in the trade winds being so important to
trade across the atlantic and indian
oceans and that interest culminated in
the map that i came here to see so here
we have the philosophical transactions
in 1686 so just a few years later so
this is the the headline paper the
journal that the royal society produces
that's right so philosophical
transactions is our major journal still
being produced it's the world's
oldest
properly scientific journal and you can
see as a frontispiece to this particular
issue this rather wonderful and quite
large map
a map of the world
and you can see wind directions marked
to help the conception of the reader in
a matter of so much difficulty i believe
it necessary to adjoin a scheme showing
at one view all the various tracks and
courses of these wins whereby it is
possible the thing may be better
understood than by any verbal
description whatsoever very scientific
you give a figure as as somebody who has
studied the atmosphere for so long this
is it's a really foundational text this
this is a really key moment in the
history of the atmosphere and it's
interesting he he goes worldwide as far
as he could see he talks about the
southern great southern ocean as well
and um
the various parts where
traders would go so you've got arabia
persia india
but this is yes so this is um
effectively one of the first papers and
what we would now call climatology
so so this is a global view of
the atmospheric system and
it's only when you look at it at this
global scale that you identify these
patterns that are being caused by
planetary scale phenomena so how did
hallie construct this map where did he
get the data from
um obviously he couldn't travel to all
of these places
he did he managed to get quite quite far
afield in
the atlantic uh what he calls the
ethiopic ocean here but he uh could
gather
uh existing written reports and he could
uh solicit information from people the
ross said he was very good at sending
lists out of things they wanted to know
from far from places and they would get
replies back and of course
naval captains and merchants would also
be able to supply information it's
surprising how far
people got at this period i mean we do
tend to think of the world as as quite
limited in the 17th century but they
were trading as as far away as as
korea
china and japan at that period
but it wasn't uh a sort of hum [ __ ]
idea of going out to take data this was
you're going along this way and we'd
like you to take some measurements for
us so so if if they knew an ambassador
that was going overseas if then you were
a sea captain or a trader uh they they
could solicit information that way and
an awful lot of this
is
is information that has come from
activities
that
you know they're effectively efforts of
colonization or proto-colonization well
that's right i mean you mentioned the
trade winds uh uh and trade with the
americas of course this this is exactly
the period when uh the slave traders
begin and the tropics from one part of
the triangle from exactly right yes yeah
yeah so this is this map is a milestone
in atmospheric history and it is amazing
to touch it but it does have that debt
to a really
horrible part of human history
absolutely right yes hallie believed
that the trade winds were caused by the
warmth of the sun pushing air masses in
front of it consistently from east to
west there is however a very obvious
problem with this explanation the trade
winds are localized to a narrow band of
latitudes near the equator while
halley's theory implies that they should
exist from pole to pole halley was aware
of this problem and so he implored
others to take up the task of explaining
the tradewinds eventually his call was
answered by of all things a lawyer also
connected to the royal society even at
this this period you no one earned their
living as a scientist really well the
term didn't even exist exactly right so
you might well be a lawyer or a trader
of some kind of merchant uh you might be
a physician or an aristocrat and you
would do science as a kind of a not
quite a hobby but
it wasn't your way of earning a living
you were a gentleman scholar you part of
the other activities that's right and
it's amazing how
how neat this is it's it's what one two
three four four and a half pages uh half
of which is sort of a very pleasant
greeting really to the problem and it's
it's just a verbal explanation in stark
contrast to what haley did
you know using a visual aid
what in a modern paper you would
absolutely have a diagram yes so uh this
is later since we're into the 1730s now
into the 18th century and uh this is
george hadley's paper concerning the
cause of the tradewinds which you're now
going to explain to me
well seeing as you are so nicely keith
hadley considered what happens when air
moves towards the equator towards the
area of low pressure that rings the
earth as it moves towards the equator
from both north and south air is
deflected westwards hadley reasoned that
this happened in order to conserve the
air's linear momentum by increasing its
distance from the earth's axis it must
decelerate but this deceleration acts in
the opposite direction to the earth's
rotation and so is perceived by someone
at the surface as an acceleration in a
westward direction i know it's a bit
mind melty this idea took a long time to
catch on we now think of the tradewinds
as the return flow of a huge
three-dimensional circulation that we
call the general circulation air rises
over the warm equator moves polewards
both north and south and then eventually
starts to sink again however by rising
over the equator it left behind an area
of low pressure which sucks the air back
in before rising once more closing the
loop after hadley we call this
circulation the hadley cell
but as it turns out hadley was only
nearly correct in his explanation as
there's an extra kind of momentum to
consider when explaining the tradewinds
as derived by coriolis to find out more
about that you'll just have to read or
listen to my book firmament an
introduction to atmospheric science out
now linked in the description so what
we've seen here is two scientists who
have been very tied to the royal society
and have used that
their connection to this nexus of
information to form these events
what is the role of the royal society in
the history in scientific history at
this time is this a very common thing
that we're seeing across lots of
sciences
yeah so um learned societies
have a network of scholars attached to
them so this is the fellowship you know
the the royal society isn't really a
place or a building it's a it's a
collective of scientists and at this
period they would correspond not just
with the royal society but uh between
themselves that's right
exactly right and this is how ideas got
propagated it's how information was
gathered so um organizations like the
royal society which encouraged this kind
of activity
were very important indeed halle as well
as being an amazing scientist was also
for a time a sea captain he undertook
voyages throughout the atlantic
including the first purely scientific
voyage ever by an english vessel this
all took place during the 17th century a
time when europe extended its influence
around the world partly enabled by the
tradewinds hallie described to
understand the modern world you need to
understand the history of this time a
story laid out in ambitions and
conquests part of the story of europe's
series with dr christopher clark nice
name available on curiositystream
curiositystream is the home of thousands
of professionally produced documentaries
perfect to pop on while you're eating
dinner and learn something new you can
get access at my link
curiositystream.com simonclark and get
26 off a subscription but more than that
you also get access to nebula if
curiositystream is the home of big
budget professional documentaries nebula
is the home of indie educational content
owned and operated by a large number of
independent educational content creators
here there are no ads there's no
algorithm and there's plenty of
exclusive content such as wendover's
recent documentary on the colorado river
or real-life laws series on modern
conflicts nebula is our alternative to
youtube that pushes the boundaries of
what educational video online can
achieve to support my work and get
access to curiosity stream and nebula
head to curiositystream.com simon clark
i promise you you won't regret it with
thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching the video
all the way through to the end thanks
must also go to keith who was just
phenomenal in helping me in this video i
had a fantastic time filming in the raw
society with him fingers crossed i get
to do some more filming with him in the
future if you'd like some recommended
viewing next there's some suggestions up
on the screen and if you're not already
then please do subscribe to the channel
so you can be notified when i make more
videos like this one thank you again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one